hello there I gaff I'm done now you may
have noticed that a we are the slow mo
guys and B we are very hairy very hairy
I'm half-italian won't leave you'll have
to tell you between us we are one
Italian man not to do but yeah got a
microwaveable waxing kit here yeah we do
something about it and wax I'm filming
in slow-mo have you ever wanted to see
hairs fly out of skin and super slow-mo
I have actually yeah me too I think it'd
be disgusting chill pill let's film it
thoughts well it's high up no I'll see
it course cuz you wear short shorts yeah
it's not Italy in the 80s baby but
unless you're sure it's leather one
patch of skin just like feels either but
I swear alopecia my name go for it right
that's very good that's incredible
[Music]
[Music]
okay well that's the decent-looking shop
but I want to get a lot closer just to
see if I can see individual hairs now
sadly I don't have a macro lens and this
lenses minimum focus is about here and I
want to be focusing here now not the end
of the world there is a trick you can do
you just pull the lens off flip it
around try and cover the hole as best
you can not let any light in and now my
minimum focus is around here what this
is a nifty trick I don't know that was a
thing yeah that's impressive I'll just
learn something that's cool yeah all
right now the downside is I can't
actually use this focus ring anymore or
the aperture so I have to preset those
and then just tilt in and out with the
actual camera itself and push the button
and trigger the camera so a bit of a
mission this one but we'll see what we
can get that's cool okay what
[Music]
okay
[Music]
dan it's always you who gets all the fun
it's fun
yep for some West I don't like look at
my legs on your legs
haha
it really does hurt
[Music]
[Music]
well done that was just as disgusting as
I hoped it and painful and painful this
is bleeding yeah a little tiny bits of
blood mine is uh Oh looks like chickens
my it looks like a plucked chicken it
does and yours looks like blood beef oh
I don't do it ever again I think we
gonna give me such weird looks the most
amazing thing to me about that aside
from the hair getting plucked out was
how the skin just hovers up in the air
after it's been plucked like there's so
much give in the skin and ripple so much
in slo-mo it lasts so much longer as
well so it looks like the skin is
completely distort here ages deformed
hump yeah there eventually settles back
down that's quite cool that's very
fascinating yeah hopefully you enjoyed
that video feel free to follow us on
Twitter we have a second channel that
you can subscribe to that's quite good
there's a behind-the-scenes on there
couple of fa Q's couple of questions
we're filling that up as much as we can
and buy so much if you'd like to yeah
thank you very much for watching we'll
see you in a few weeks
[Music]
you